this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of madden nfl 21 mobile
football
[Music]
from the character who will be rebooted
every few years until all movies are
batman
comes the feature-length version of the
cartoon that babysat an entire
generation of latchkey nerds
thank you bad daddy batman
mask of the phantasm you've seen the
story of how batman began
a lot okay once more for good measure
okay that's enough i said enough
now strap in to learn the cost that
breaking bat took on bruce's soul
because this cartoon is less about
gadgets and beat-em-ups and more about
the scars of a man
who took on an impossible burden i
didn't count on being happy
how much of this movie takes place in a
graveyard most of it
fun enter the cd underbelly of gotham
where the skyscrapers are tall and the
world's fairs go ham
to suit up with the batman a collection
of rectangles
and feelings as he takes on a new baddie
the phantasm i think they never actually
say it out loud they're a grim reaper
with a power of atmospheric farts
[Music]
who uses their martial arts and crab
claw to take out some of the oldest
fattest mobsters in gotham
[Music]
thrill as batman rekindles an old flame
and andrea beaumont
another classic entry in bruce's we're
too damaged to make it work dating
history
even though they both share a love for
jiu jitsu and dead parents who are you
talking to
my mother what would a batman be without
a joker
unprofitable so mark hamill shows up
halfway through this one
watch his tank fall somewhere between
heath ledger's chaotic intensity
caesar romero's gentlemanly warning
before he tries to blow you up
i'm sending you a fun gift
in five minutes everything goes up
you're not batman after all
and jared leto's possibility that he
would be banging a robotic maid for fun
you get in the mood and company shows up
come on you really think they do the
first animated batman movie with an
original villain we live in an infinite
universe with an infinite capacity for
more joker stuff
so return to the art deco nightmare of
pauldini's gotham
for an animated classic that deserves to
be at the top of your best bad list
by proving the best way to make batman
for adult audiences
isn't with violence even though the in
this is pretty sick
[Music]
or by porking bad girl for no good
reason although this bad bad
definitely but by pulling off what
creators have been trying to do
since the beginning make a cool noir
story about a guy who dresses
like a bat that reflects on how sad it
is that he can't stop doing
so much awesome punching it's just
so very sad
[Music]
starring the bachelor
phanta fanta don't you want a fanta
fanta you ever dance with the devil at
the abandoned world's fair
lord business r.i.p abe vegota
fast and the furious six or was it seven
when they did that
maybe five zim's mom put a sock in the
door bruce
[Music]
the ending of hot fuzz and bats wins
batman forever alone
geez mr saul i can't tell the difference
it's identical down to ben franklin
stubble
huh this seems like the kind of thing
the fbi could probably handle rather
than you know
a violent vigilante didn't realize
batman even had a white collar crime
division
this episode is sponsored by google play
get madden nfl 21 mobile football
and discover more on google play now
i found their weakness without their
heads they're powerless
you are depriving some village of their
idiot
wakanda forever